[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halbweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann
für den
Sportthemen von heute
Besuch mit Ballast im Gepäck
Bundeskanzler Scholz versucht bei Chinas
machthabarchie den Spagat zwischen
Kooperation und Kritik
Rückschlag für die Meeresfauna die Pläne
für ein riesiges Antarktis Schutzgebiet
scheitern erneut am Widerstand aus China
und Russland
und die unbekannte Seite von Marc
Chagall eine Ausstellung in Frankfurt am
Main zeigt Werke aus den 30er und 40er
Jahren
[Musik]
es war ein kurzer heikler Tagestrip des
Kanzlers nach China gerade in Krisen sei
das direkte Gespräch wichtig so
verteidigte Scholz seinen umstrittenen
Antrittsbesuch bei Machthaber hising
Ping der wurde in Bezug auf Russlands
Krieg in der Ukraine unerwartet deutlich
der Einsatz von nuklearen Waffen oder
die Drogen damit müsse abgelehnt werden
aus Peking berichtet Miriam Steimer
Peking rollt im deutschen Kanzler den
roten Teppich aus und trägt dabei die
Angst zur Schau dass die Gäste des
Coronavirus im Gepäck haben könnten
willkommen im null-koppelt China das
chinesische Staatsfernsehen zeigt Olaf
Scholz wie er Staatschef hier den pingen
zuhört und nickt China freut sich über
Scholz Gastgeschenk den cosco-deal mit
dem Hamburger Hafen
es läuft nach Chinas Spielregeln Scholz
ist der erste westliche Besuch wenige
Tage nach dem Parteitag bei dem hi den
ein Parteienstaat zu einer
einmanndiktatur umgebaut hat
trotz viel Kritik ist Scholz gekommen
und betont wie wichtig das sei auch
wegen des Kriegs in der Ukraine
staatspräsidentie und ich sind uns einig
atomare Drohgebärden sind
unverantwortlich und brandgefährlich
mit dem Einsatz von Atomwaffen würde
Russland eine Linie überschreiten die
die Staatengemeinschaft gemeinsam
gezogen hat
auch den scheidenden Regierungschef für
den skiab März keinen Platz mehr in
seiner Führungsmannschaft hat
wir hoffen alle auf ein baldiges Ende
der ukraine-krise es ist an der Zeit
beide Seiten zufriedensgesprächen zu
bewegen
Scholz spricht Taiwan an und auch die
Menschenrechte
die Umsetzung dieser Rechte anzumahnen
zum Beispiel in der Provinz 10 Yang ist
deswegen keine Einmischung in innere
Angelegenheiten doch vor allem geht es
ums Geschäft er reist mit einer
Wirtschaftsdelegation und verkündet die
Zulassung des biontech-impfstoffs in
China zunächst allerdings nur für
Ausländer die hier leben
der Besuch des Kanzlers war ja vorab in
der Kritik fragen wir Thomas Reichert
der Olaf Scholz begleitet was ist die
Bilanz auf der Habenseite
also auf der Habenseite kann ich Scholz
sicher verbuchen dass er erreicht hat
dass China ganz offenbar bereit ist
Druck auf Russland auszuüben seine
nuklearen Drohgebärden bleiben zu lassen
die Botschaft die Scholz gerne hätte von
Peking nach Moskau ist denkt noch mal
nicht denkt noch nicht mal daran
Nuklearwaffen einzusetzen China deutlich
gemacht dass es dass der Krieg nicht in
seinem Interesse ist dass er die eigene
Wirtschaft den eigenen Handel
durcheinander bringt und scheint sich da
bewegen zu wollen allerdings wie weit
das geht gegen den eigenen Verbündeten
gegen Russland das ist noch meine ganz
andere Frage
schaut es mit großer
Wirtschaftsdelegation angereist war das
erfolgreich
da ist die Bilanz hier durchwachsen und
ich glaube da hat Scholz wenig erreichen
können das was wir auf der
Pressekonferenz eben vom chinesischen
Ministerpräsidenten Liquid Chang gehört
haben das waren gemein Plätze die man
von dieser Seite seit Jahren hört und da
muss man dazu wissen die Chang gilt in
China als reforma und wird im nächsten
Jahr ersetzt durch eine schiefe
vertrauten ein Hardliner der vermutlich
für noch mehr Staats- und Planwirtschaft
steht das sind wenig Erfolge
wahrscheinlich zu verbuchen für deutsche
Unternehmen die eine fairere Behandlung
einen besseren Marktzugang in China sich
gewünscht hätten insofern also insgesamt
für Scholz eine durchaus durchwachsene
pekingbilanz danke für diese
Einschätzung aus Peking Thomas Reichert
war das
das Gespräch haben wir vor dem Rückflug
unseres Korrespondenten aufgezeichnet
schauen wir in die Ukraine im Süden im
russisch besetzten verhängte der
Stadthalter eine Ausgangssperre seine
Begründung ist Ruhe ein Angriff auf die
Stadt auch heute wurden wieder Bürger
aus herrsson nach Russland oder auf die
Krim gebracht
unterdessen in Kiew deutscher Besuch
Justizminister Buschmann versprachhilfe
für den EU-Beitritt damit die Ukraine
die rechtsstaatlichen Standards für das
Aufnahmeverfahren erfüllen kann
kann es sein dass ein deutsches
Unternehmen trotz des Angriffs auf die
Ukraine einen Rohstoff liefert mit dem
Flugbenzin für russische Kampfbomber
produziert wird das Legen Recherchen vom
ZDF-Magazin frontal und dem spiegelnahe
der Mineralölkonzern wintershaldea weiß
die Vorwürfe zurück über die
Hintergründe Frederik Obermeier und Hans
groberstein
fast täglich russische Luftangriffe auf
ukrainische Städte zerstörte Gebäude
viele getötete Zivilisten verantwortlich
auch russische Jagdbomber wir
kontinuierliche Versorgung mit
Treibstoff insbesondere mit Treibstoff
ist von großer Bedeutung damit die
Flugzeuge immer bereit sind immer
fliegen können
der größte Hersteller von Flug Benzin in
Russland ist Gazprom er hat nach
Recherchen von ZDF und Spiegel luft-
wintersaldea weist solche Vorwürfe als
unzutreffend zurück Zitat unsere joint
venture-gesellschaften in Russland
beliefern nicht das russische Militär
mit Gaskondensat fest steht Gazprom
verarbeitet das Gaskondensat und die
gazprompraffinerie in Omsk belieferte
nach Recherchen von ZDF und Spiegel 9
Militärflughäfen seit Kriegsbeginn
die stellvertretende Justizministerin in
der Ukraine fordert von der
Bundesregierung eine Untersuchung
der Aktivität von wintersaldea ein
Kriegsverbrechen herausstellt dann
sollte der Fall dem Internationalen
Strafgerichtshof übergeben werden
der müsste klären ob und wie sehr
wintersaldea tatsächlich verstrickt ist
in den russischen Angriffskrieg der
Konzern prüft indes eine rechtliche
Trennung von seinem Russlandgeschäft
mehr zu den Vorwürfen in der nächsten
Ausgabe von Frontal am Dienstag um 21
Uhr und schon jetzt in der ZDF heute App
wer Krieg in der Ukraine ist auch Thema
beim zweiten Tag der G7 Runde in Münster
die Außenminister warnten Russland vor
einer weiteren Eskalation des Kriegs
scharfe Kritik auch an Iran wegen der
anhaltenden Gewalt gegen Demonstranten
die Kernbotschaft der Runde der sieben
Einigkeit und Geschlossenheit Andreas
kühners fasst den Tag zusammen
hier kommt der neue hier kommt Italien
hier kommt die überaus Putin freundliche
Berlusconi-Partei aber Außenminister
Tajani ist so erfahren dass er seine
Krawatte im Gehen bindet und dass er
seine Kollegen nicht gleich beim ersten
Treffen verstimmt dass die G7
geschlossen bleiben ist die wichtigste
Nachricht aus Münster dass sie der
Ukraine gemeinsam durch den Winter
helfen wollen mit Heizgeräten
pumpengeneratoren und mit der EU deren
außenbeauftragter
zu spät ist aber im Namen der
Mitgliedstaaten Beteiligung zusagt die
G7 sind sich einig den ukrainischen
Energiesektor zu reparieren und zu
verteidigen den Präsident Putin versucht
ausbluten zu lassen
die g7-vorsitzende baerbock hat
Gleichgesinnte eingeladen Kenia Ghana
die Afrikanische Union Ziel
Zusammenarbeiten mit allen die die
westlichen Werte teilen
Unterschiede werden beim Umgang mit Iran
sichtbar während Frankreichs
Außenministerin vor allem auf neue
Sanktionen drängt will auch Deutschland
das atomabkommen Retten ich bin zutiefst
davon überzeugt der Iran das Regime wird
nicht besser dadurch wenn Sie ein
Atomwaffe haben sondern es wird nur noch
schlimmer werden für die regionale
Sicherheit dann gehen für die Menschen
in Münster zwei Tage Ausnahmezustand zu
Ende mit wenig konkretem aber viel gutem
Willen
bitteres Zeugnis für die deutsche
Klimapolitik zu wenig zu langsam zu spät
und zu inkonsequent sei sie so dass
Urteil des von der Bundesregierung
beauftragten expertenrats in seinem
ersten Gutachten heißt es wenn es so
weitergeht sein weder die selbst
gesteckten noch die internationalen
Klimaziele zu erreichen
wenig Hoffnung macht auch der Blick in
die Antarktis dort sollte das größte
Meeresschutzgebiet der Welt entstehen
doch dieser Plan ist auf einer Tagung
wieder gescheitert wieder am Widerstand
von China und Russland konkret geht es
um eine Fläche von fast 4 Millionen
Quadratkilometern in der Antarktis
besonders geschützt wäre dann das
artenreiche weddelmeer ein
Rückzugsgebiet für Seehechte
grillkrebstiere und Kaiserpinguine
Norman Odenthal über die Interessen am
Südpol
eine Reise in die Antarktis macht man
nicht alle Tage und nicht ohne Grund
Neuseelands Premierministerin ist in die
Kälte geflogen sie interessiert sich für
den Stand der Klimaforschung aber macht
auch klar es geht um mehr justice wir
leben in einer Zeit in der viele Teile
der Welt umstritten sind umworben im
internationalen Wettbewerb so auch die
Antarktis nicht nur für Neuseeland ist
es wichtig seine starke Position zu
behaupten
strategische Optionen wirtschaftliche
Ziele die Antarktis lockt viele auch die
Chinesen brechen gerade wieder auf lasst
uns diese Reise antreten und zu einer
neuen era beitragen im Auftrag unseres
Volkes wenn alle diese Ambitionen nur
dem Klimaschutz dienten stünde es besser
um die polare Welt Erderwärmung lässt
das Eis schmelzen das ist die große
Dimension die Kleinen sind aber nicht
weniger wichtig
Grill Garnelen ähnliche Tiere sind
zentraler Teil der Nahrungskette im
Ökosystem doch Wale etwa konkurrieren
mit dem Hunger der Kosmetik und
Pharmaindustrie auch die will Grill
Schutzzonen Fangverbote China und
Russland sperren sich einmal sind bei
bestimmten Ländern kommerzielle
Interessen sehr hoch und dann ist
natürlich auch ein sehr großes Problem
die weltpolitische Lage wieder auch in
diesen Entscheidungsprozessen sehr stark
mit reinfällt heißt Kriege und Krisen
verderben die Kompromissbereitschaft das
ist kein gutes Klima für Klimaschutz
zurück nach Deutschland die
Ampelkoalition hat sich auf Änderungen
an dem geplanten Hartz IV Nachfolger dem
Bürgergeld verständigt damit will sie
eine Schlappe im Bundesrat verhindern
denn die Union verweigert die Zustimmung
zu dem Gesetz so soll es einige
Verschärfungen geben zum Beispiel bei
der Übernahme der Heizkosten und bei der
Karenzzeit ob das Gesetz damit durchgeht
ist offen
die hohen Lebenshaltungskosten der Krieg
die Unsicherheit das treibt viele
Menschen auf die Straße vor allem im
Osten gibt es seit Wochen Proteste gegen
die Politik der Bundesregierung bislang
blieben sie weitgehend friedlich doch
die Sorge vor wachsendem Einfluss von
Rechtsextremisten ist groß das war heute
Thema der Innenminister der Ostländer in
Erfurt Melanie Haack hat mehr
unsere aller sie singen vom Frieden und
schimpfen auf die russland-sanktionen
Sonneberg Thüringen am Montag eine Demo
von vielen in Ostdeutschland es geht um
die Energie-
unsere politische Führung hat vor zwei
Jahren die Pharmaindustrie geheiratet
und nun geht sie auch noch mit der
Rüstungsindustrie ins Bett weil es nimmt
ich meine wir gehen von von einer Krise
in die nächste die Leute sind immer mehr
davon betroffen
keiner weiß mehr weiter mit dabei aber
auch afd-vertreter es Wehen bei
rechtsextremen und reichsbürgern
beliebte Fahnen legitima Protest wird
hier und in vielen anderen ostdeutschen
Städten unterwandert sagen Experten die
Gefahr ist schon in der Tat dass wir
dann in eine protestkern Menschen
beobachten die sich derartig
radikalisieren dass am Ende des Tages
dann eben der Sturz des politischen
Systems propagiert wird wie damit
umgehen heute Thema beim Treffen der
ostdeutschen Innenminister in Erfurt
länderübergreifend wollen Sie künftig
rechtsextreme Strukturen zerschlagen
wir müssen in Rechtsextremismus überall
dort wo er sich zeigt in all seinen
Ausprägungen sei es Rechtsrock
Kampfsport Demonstrationen müssen wir
ihn stellen müssen wir ihn bekämpfen
dazu haben sie vereinbart ein Netzwerk
aus Experten
Ämtern und Behörden zu bilden
nach der Übernahme von Twitter treibt
Elon mask den Umbau des
Kurznachrichtendienstes voran mit
massiven Entlassungen die heute per
E-Mail verschickt wurden laut
Medienberichten könnte etwa die Hälfte
der 7.500 Angestellten von den
Kündigungen betroffen sein die Büros
bleiben vorübergehend geschlossen wohl
als Vorsichtsmaßnahme um eventuelle
Proteste auszuschließen der reichste
Mann der Welt hatte Twitter vergangene
Woche für rund 44 Milliarden Euro
gekauft danach entließ er direkt
leitende Manager
werfen wir noch einen Blick auf eine
besondere Ausstellung eine Hommage an
Marc Chagall jeder kennt die bunten
Bilder des französisch-russischen
Künstlers die Frankfurter schirren
widmet sich seiner eher düsteren Periode
schmerzvolle eindringliche Zeugnisse der
30er und 40er Jahre Welt in Aufruhr
heißt die Schau irgendwie auch passend
für unsere Zeit Peter Tyson
das ist der Chagall den wir alle kennen
das mystisch himmlische blau leuchtende
Farben grenzenlose Fantasie und
Lebensfreude doch der
jahrhundertkünstler durchlebt in den
30ern 40er Jahren eine schwere Zeit
seine Heimat im heutigen Belarus
verlässt der jüdische Künstler für immer
Chagall geht ins Exil nach Paris und
später New York Krieg Heimweh Flucht
auch verzweiflungssystemen dieser Werke
deshalb sind die Bilder von Chagall in
dieser Ausstellung auch etwas dunkler
spürbar traurig Schautag auf diese Welt
in Aufruhr das bunte weicht immer mehr
den Grautönen das Leiden der
europäischen Juden verarbeitete er so
der Gekreuzigte trägt das jüdische
gebetstuch der kombiniert dieses Bild
eben auch mit zeitgenössischen Elementen
die hier zum Beispiel dieses
Flüchtlingsschiff was eben ein moderner
Dampfer ist ein weiteres Schlüsselwerk
wird der Sturz des Engels der Schrecken
angesichts von Krieg und schora steht
ihm ins Gesicht geschrieben in die Zeit
fällt dann auch noch das persönliche
Drama der Tod seiner geliebten Frau
Bella und doch spricht aus den Bildern
nicht nur Verzweiflung
und dieser Kontrast des emotionalen also
zwischen Hoffnung und Verzweiflung immer
auch wieder hin zur Rettung das ist in
seinen Werken wirklich ein ganz
entscheidender Augenblick am Ende einer
dunklen Zeit scheint schon wieder der
fantastische Chagall durch mit seiner
einzigartigen Originalität vielleicht
ist es diese Kreativität die ihn davor
bewahrt hat aufzugeben
ja kreativ muss jetzt auch der
Bundestrainer sein Norbert die Frage ist
Vene als Stürmer mitnimmt zur WM nach
Cotta nach dem verletzungsbedingten
Ausfall von Timo werner hat
Bundestrainer Hansi Flick wirklich
weniger Alternativen auf der klassischen
neunerposition mögliche Kandidaten etwa
der Bremer Niklas Füllkrug und auch
Kevin Volland vom AS Monaco
nach der Warschauer Verletzung vom
Mittwoch ist Timo Werners aktueller
WM-Traum beendet sein Umfeld sucht Trost
in der ferneren Zukunft wir haben dann
schon glaube ich auch alle auf dem
Schirm das ist weitergeht dass wir ihn
wieder fit bekommen dass er hoffentlich
bald wieder der Alte ist und dann gibt
es da noch eine WM ein paar Jahren
möglicherweise
schießt uns dann zum wm-tippen so lange
kann Hansi fliegt nicht warten der
Bundestrainer muss gucken wer sonst noch
zur Tour Gefahr taugt Kevin vollandte in
Monaco spielt brachte sich
passenderweise gestern mit drei Toren in
der Europa League beim Sieg gegen
Belgrad in Erinnerung Lukas Matcha vom
VfL Wolfsburg wird von Experten ins
Spiel gebracht und natürlich der Bremer
Niklas Füllkrug der neuen Saisontore
vorzuweisen hat wäre es auch immer wird
den Vergleich mit Werner wird er
aushalten müssen
zu den europäischen Pokalwettbewerben
gestern Abend in der Conference liegt da
ist der 1 fC Köln nach dem 2:2 gegen
Nizza ausgeschieden in der Europa liegt
dagegen sind Freiburg und auch Union
eine Runde weiter der entscheidende
Treffer zum einzelnen Sieg der Berliner
Vieh bereits in der sechsten Spielminute
nach toller Flanke von Geraldo Becker
brachte Sven Michel den Ball über die
Linie danach ließ Union kaum noch echte
Chancen für Gastgebers Gil du hast so am
Ende ein verdienter Sieg gegen die
Belgier übrigens der vierte 1:0 erfolgt
der Köpenicker in der Europa League in
Folge
Rio Olympiasiegerin Laura Ludwig hat zum
ersten Mal seit ihrer Babypause ein
Beachvolleyball Match gewonnen im
zweiten Spiel beim pro-tour-turnier in
Kapstadt besiegte die 36-Jährige
zusammen mit ihrer neuen Partnerin Luisa
Lippmann die Japanerin Suzuka Hashimoto
und Raika morakani mit zwei zu null ja
das Ziel der beiden natürlich in der
Medaille bei den Olympischen Spielen in
Paris 2024
schauen wir mal ja jetzt erstmal
Wochenende das wird herzlich die Details
zum Wetter hat gleich Christa Erben um
10 begrüßt Sie Christian Sievers im
heute-journal wir wünschen Ihnen ein
unbeschwertes Wochenende machen sie es
gut und bis morgen wenn Sie mögen auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]